so this has always been my hope is when
you do the stand-up on a late night show
there's no sit-down time afterwards so
I'm here with Adam cayton-holland who
just did awesome stand-up and we're
doing it like you know the old Tonight
Show when when I got called over this
means I've made it in the industry now I
mean late night Turner networks you are
in 100% I'll take it
how'd it feel out there you feel good
what if that's what it was how do you
feel each joke Tim what if I came with
like a really 70% C student it was
killer how is it waiting backstage it's
always tense for me yeah it's a little
nerve-wracking but then you got those
guys back there who are like yeah kid we
see a million of these every day and
you're like okay this is yeah yeah this
is my dream not there and you were
talking about baseball a lot and you're
from Denver I am and they have a they
have a bait I understand they have a
they know are you big sports guy no yeah
okay there's baseball team in Denver
called the Colorado Rockies uh-huh there
are a few people are wooing that's
that's incorrect
they're a fun organization but they're a
terrible one why is that
oh they've been around 21 years and
they've made the playoffs three times in
that 21 years that's not a good rate
they didn't win they just made that just
made the playoffs once they went to the
World Series but I've been a fan since
the day one we've had season tickets
since 1993 so I've been campaigning to
let the Rockies throw out the ceremonial
first pitch
I want to go throw a ceremonial first
you want to throw that I want to throw
it out at Coors Field in Denver Colorado
and so I've started like a Twitter
hashtag it's called ACH first pitch and
the Rockies are ignoring me completely
so I was like maybe I'll just go on the
Pete Holmes show and talk about in a
national television
happen so I'm gonna I applaud that that
seems difficult to me I would rather
sing the national anthem
oh then throw the pitch because I'm so
afraid of just that I don't want to put
this in your head sure sure that perfect
moment when you go back and your hands
are clammy because you're nervous and is
your favorite team you like I've been
coming since 93
so there's sweat and then it just falls
out and we just kind of throw it and the
ball just plops behind you like you took
a small white deuce that was not a fear
I had until right now
yeah just tear your shoulder well I'm
working the ear style throw in superhot
speed right great see now you're talking
my language angels in the outfield sure
care but fun family sports movies
I'll watch those Adam